FIREARM ALSO BE PRESENT WHILE
TRUMP IS PRESENT.
I GUESS WHAT GOES FOR HIM
DOESN'T GO FOR EVERYONE ELSE.
IT COMES AS REPUBLICANS SUGGEST
THERE IS NOTHING TO BE DONE TO
PREVENT THESE SHOOTINGS.
ACCUSING OTHERS OF POLITICIZING
THE TRAGEDY.
>> THE TRUTH IS, THESE PEOPLE
ARE GOING TO COMMIT THESE
HORRIFYING CRIMES, THEY'LL
FIGURE OUT A WAY TO DO IT.
>> I CAN'T ASSURE THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE THERE'S ANY LAW WE CAN
PASS TO STOP THESE SHOOTINGS.
>> YOU SEE POLITICIANS TRY TO
POLITICIZE THESE THINGS.
YOU SEE DEMOCRATS AND FOLKS IN
THE MEDIA, WHOSE IMMEDIATE
SOLUTION IS TO TRY TO RESTRICT
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS OF LAW
ABIDING CITIZENS.
>> "OUTFRONT" NOW, FORMER
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN WILL
HEARD WHO REPRESENTED THE UVALDE
COMMUNITY FOR SIX YEARS IN
CONGRESS.
AND PAUL BEGALA, POLITICAL
COMMENTATOR.
TO SAY SOMEONE WITH A KNIFE CAN
COULD IN AND SLAUGHTER 21
PEOPLE, IT IS NOT RIGHT.
SO WHEN YOU HEAR TRUMP AND OTHER
REPUBLICANS HEADING TO TEXAS FOR
THE NRA MEETING, TRUMP
CONFIRMING TODAY, SENATORS ON
CAPITOL HILL, DISMISSING IDEAS
FOR GUN CONTROL, WHAT DO YOU SAY
TO THEM?
>> ANYBODY THAT SAYS THERE'S
NOTHING THAT CAN BE DONE IS JUST
ABSOLUTELY WRONG.
THERE'S A LOT OF DIFFERENT
THINGS THAT CAN BE DONE.
THERE'S NOT JUST ONE MAGIC FIX
THAT'S GOING TO SOLVE ALL OF
THIS PROBLEM.
YOU KNOW, IN TEXAS, WHY DO YOU
HAVE TO BE 21 TO HAVE A HAND GUN
BUT YOU CAN BE 18 TO HAVE A
SEMIAUTOMATIC RIFLE?
THAT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE.
IF YOU GO IN AND PURCHASE A
WEAPON, EVERYBODY SHOULD HAVE A
BACK GROUND CHECK.
I WAS ONE OF THE FEW REPUBLICANS
THAT VOTED IN SUPPORT OF HRA,
THAT'S THE PIECE OF LEGISLATION
THAT'S OFTEN BROUGHT UP WHEN
THESE DEBATES HAPPEN, THE ONE
THAT COACH KERR FROM THE GOLDEN
STATE WARRIORS WAS TALKING ABOUT
THE OTHER NIGHT.
WE COULD BE TALKING ABOUT ISSUES
OF MENTAL HEALTH.
YES, THE PEOPLE THAT CONDUCT
THIS, THE KID THAT DID THIS
SLAUGHTER IN UVALDE IS A
MONSTER.
THE KID THAT KILLED PEOPLE IN
BUFFALO IS A MONSTER.
WHEN I WAS IN CONGRESS, THE KID
THAT KILLED PEOPLE IN EL PASO
WERE MONSTERS.
BUT THEY DIDN'T START OFF THAT
WAY.
HOW DO WE GET TO THEM BEFORE
THEY MAKE THAT DECISION TO DO
THESE THINGS?
LET'S STUDY THIS, LET'S
UNDERSTAND WHAT THIS IS GOING
ON.
I ONLY KNOW OF TWO RESEARCHERS
THAT HAVE REVIEWED ALL OF THE
MASS SHOOTINGS SINCE 1966.
THEY CALL IT THE VIOLENCE
PROJECT.
SO THAT WE UNDERSTAND ALL THE
THINGS THAT WE CAN BE DOING,
IT'S NOT JUST ONE, IT'S MULTIPLE
THINGS THAT NEED TO BE HAPPENING
AT THE SAME TIME.
ANYBODY, REPUBLICAN OR DEMOCRAT,
THAT SAYS THERE'S NOTHING THAT
CAN BE DONE FOR THIS, THEN SHAME
ON THEM.
>> SO, YOU KNOW, PAUL, YOU HEAR
BETO O'ROURKE, DEMOCRATIC
CANDIDATE FOR GOVERNOR,
CONFRONTED GOVERNOR ABBOTT AT A
PRESS CONFERENCE ON THE
SHOOTING.
TAKE A LISTEN WHAT HAPPENED.
>> SIR, YOU ARE OUT OF LINE!
SIR, YOU ARE OUT OF LINE!
GET OUT OF HERE, GET OUT OF
HERE.
>> I CAN'T BELIEVE YOU SICK SON
OF A BITCH.
>> THAT WAS THE UVALDE MAYOR.
JUST BEFORE THAT HAPPENED, PAUL,
BETO O'ROURKE SENT OUT A
CAMPAIGN EMAIL ABOUT THE
SHOOTING.
THE EMAIL DOES SAY, GRASSROOTS
SUPPORTERS LIKE US KEEP US GOING
AND DIRECTING THEM TO A MAILING
ADDRESS TO SEND CHECKS.
WAS HIS BEHAVIOR TODAY A
MISTAKE?
>> I THIS NO.
CONFRONTING THE GOVERNOR IN
PUBLIC, HE DIDN'T GO TO HIS HOME
OR BOTHER HIS FAMILY.
I THINK MORE OFFIS -- OF US
SHOULD BE A BETO.
THESE POLITICIANS WORK FOR US.
IN PUBLIC, WHEN THEY'RE AT THE
TOWN HALL MEETINGS OR TRYING TO
GET THE PRESS, I THINK IT'S
WONDERFUL, FRANKLY, TO EXPRESS
THAT RIGHTEOUS INDIGNATION.
I KNOW BETO.
HE'S A DAD.
THAT WASN'T A POLITICIAN, THAT
WAS A DAD.
>> YOU DON'T HAVE A PROBLEM IT
WAS PERFORMANCE THEATER?
THE MAYOR SAYING YOU'RE A SICK
SON OF A BITCH?
>> THE SICK PEOPLE ARE THE ONES
IN THE WAKE OF A SHOOTING -- THE
GOVERNOR SIGNED A LAW IN TEXAS
THAT SAYS YOU CAN CARRY A GUN
WITH NO CERTIFICATION, NO
LICENSING, NO LEDGE
ADMINISTRATION, NOTHING.
I LOOKED IT UP.
TO BE A KOZMA -- COSMETOLOGIST,
YOU HAVE TO HAVE TRAINING.
WHAT'S SICK IS THESE
REPUBLICANS, WILL IS RIGHT, HE
WAS ONLY ONE OF EIGHT PEOPLE TO
VOTE FOR THAT BACKGROUND CHECK,
ONLY EIGHT.
WHEN WE PASSED THE BRADY BILL,
WE HAD 54 IN THE HOUSE.
WE HAD RONALD REAGAN STANDING
UP.
SO SOMETHING HAS HAPPENED TO THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
IT'S NOT THE PARTY OF REAGAN,
IT'S A PARTY OF REALLY SICK
POLITICIANS.
>> IT HAS BECOME AN ABSOLUTISM
ON GUNS, AS BOTH OF YOU LAID
OUT.
TEXAS BEING AN EXAMPLE.
I WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT THAT IN
A SECOND.
BUT JUST TO BE CLEAR, PAUL, HOW
MANY GUNS DO YOU HAVE?
>> I'M A GUN OWNER.
I'M AN AVID HUNTER.
I SHOOT TARGETS AND I LOVE TO
HUNT, AND MY RIGHTS HAVE NEVER
BEEN INFRINGED.
I SUPPORT A BAN ON ASSAULT
WEAPONS AND HIGH CAPACITY
MAGAZINES.
>> BUT JUST TO BE CLEAR, YOU
HAVE A LOT OF GUNS.
>> YES, I DO.
>> I JUST --
>> I'M NOT ANTI-GUN AT ALL.
I'M ANTI-FELONS AND CRIMINALS
AND TERRORISTS AND I'M
ANTI-ASSAULT WEAPONS.
WE CAN DO A LOT OF COMMON SENSE
THINGS WITHOUT INFRINGES ON
RIGHTS.
>> THE THING IS, THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC AGREES WITH BOTH OF YOU.
SO MONMOUTH UNIVERSITY DID A
POLL AFTER THE PARKLAND
SHOOTING.
WHAT I FOUND FASCINATING ABOUT
THIS, THE NRA COMES OUT AND
FIGHTS FOR THIS ABSOLUTISM.
BUT THE PEOPLE WHO ARE THE
MEMBERS OF THE NRA DO NOT
SUPPORT THE NRA'S PUBLIC
POSITION.
69% IN THAT POLL OF NRA MEMBERS
SUPPORTED BACK GROUND CHECKS FOR
ALL GUN PURCHASES.
THAT'S 69% OF NRA MEMBERS.
HOW IS IT, WILL, THAT REPUBLICAN
LAWMAKERS, MANY OF THEM DO NOT
SUPPORT EXPANDING BACK GROUND
CHECKS?
THEY'RE AT ODDS WITH MEMBERS OF
THE NRA.
>> THEY'RE ALSO AT ODDS WITH THE
MAJORITY OF THE ACTUAL VOTERS IN
THE PRIMARIES.
I WAS BORN AND RAISED IN TEXAS.
RESPONSIBLE GUN OWNERS, THEY
TAKE SEVERAL DAYS OF TRAINING
BEFORE YOU GET LICENSED TO GO
HUNTING.
A RESPONSIBLE GUN OWNER LOCKS
THEIR GUNS AND AMMUNITION UP SO
NOBODY CAN HAVE ACCESS.
A RESPONSIBLE GUN OWNER KNOW
THAT THESE THINGS AND TEACH
THEIR CHILDREN HOW TO PROPERLY
USE THIS.
SO WHY ARE WE NOT SEEING MORE
MOVEMENT ON THESE ISSUES?
RESPONSIBLE GUN OWNERS DO NOT
THINK TERRORISTS AND PEOPLE THAT
HAVE SERIOUS MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES SHOULD HAVE ACCESS TO
FIREARMS.
SO THE QUESTION IS, IS NOT ABOUT
RESPONSIBLE GUN OWNERS, BECAUSE
RESPONSIBLE GUN OWNERS AGREE
WITH ALL THESE THINGS.
JUST TODAY, I THINK THE STUDY
CAME OUT ABOUT 90% OF AMERICANS
THINK SOMETHING NEEDS TO BE
DONE.
BUT WHAT WE HAVE TO PREVENT IS
WE HAVE TO PREVENT EVERYBODY
GOING TO THEIR SAME TIRED
CORNERS AND ARGUING FOR THEIR
SAME TIRED, YOU KNOW, CASE THAT
HAPPENS EVERY TIME ONE OF THESE
THINGS HAPPEN.
THERE IS NOT ONE SINGLE SOLUTION
TO THIS PROBLEM.
WE HAVE TO DO A LOT OF THINGS.
AND AT THE END OF THE DAY,
TODAY, THERE ARE 19 MOMS THAT
ARE NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO TUCK
THEIR CHILDREN AWAY.
AND WHEN YOU'VE GOT TO
UNDERSTAND ABOUT UVALDE, THIS IS
A SMALL COMMUNITY.
THEY KNOW EVERYBODY.
THIS IS NOT JUST IMPACTING THE
FAMILIES, IT'S NOT JUST
IMPACTING THE SPOUSES OF THE
TEACHERS THAT WERE KILLED.
THIS IS IMPACTING EVERYBODY.
THE POLICE OFFICERS THAT WENT IN
AND SAW THE CARNAGE, WHERE
PEOPLE HAD TO BE I.D.'d BY DNA,
THIS IS GOING TO IMPACT PEOPLE
FOR A LONG TIME TO COME.
THE PEOPLE IN SOUTHERLAND
SPRINGS FROM A COUPLE OF YEARS
AGO ARE STILL DEALING WITH THE
TRAUMA.
THE PEOPLE IN EL PASO ARE STILL
DEALING WITH THE TRAUMA.
THIS IS AN AREA WHERE WE SHOULD
BE ABLE TO GET TOGETHER AND SAY
HEY, 50% OF TEENAGE KIDS IN THIS
COUNTRY SHOULDN'T BE AFRAID OF
SOMETHING -- A MAJOR SHOOTING
EVENT HAPPENING AT THEIR SCHOOL.
AND IF THIS CONTINUES, GUESS
WHAT'S HAPPENED?
IT'S GOING TO BE HARDER AND
HARDER TO GET TEACHERS TO TEACH,
BECAUSE THEY'RE GOING TO BE
AFRAID TO BE THIS THESE SCHOOLS.
SO THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS WE
CAN BE DOING, AND IT REQUIRES
LEADERSHIP FROM DEMOCRATS.
IT REQUIRES THE GOP.
IF YOU ARE GOING TO BE THE PARTY